[Music]
you guys know that I try my best to stay
out of the day-to-day political
bickering and focus more on Big Ideas
and the philosophies which are behind
all the fighting this doesn't mean I'm
ignoring the issues of the moment be in
North Korea the gun debate or the
general state of trumpism but focusing
on why people believe what they believe
is far more valuable to me than adding
fuel to the fire of whatever the story
of the day might be toss in a healthy
dose of political gridlock and we seem
to have lots of people who are yelling
but very few people who are doing
there's one issue happening in American
politics right now which is a great
example of the stagnation we face but
that is totally flying under the radar
right now dozens of countries some of
them key strategic allies don't have
u.s. ambassadors because the Senate has
refused to vote on their confirmation
according to the rules of the Senate
right now the Senate needs 30 hours of
debate to confirm an ambassadorship you
can imagine with all the nonsensical
waste in d.c how impossible it would be
to spend 30 hours debating each of the
new ambassadorships when a new
administration comes in we'd be talking
about literally thousands of hours of
debate for a branch of government which
can't seem to agree on which flavor of
yogurt should be served at the Capitol
Hill commissary back in 2014 when the
Democrats controlled the Senate then
Majority Leader Harry Reid used what is
known as the nuclear option to get many
Obama appointees through the Senate in
effect Reid changed the rules so that a
simple majority rather than a 60-vote
supermajority would be enough to confirm
ambassadors federal judges and other
positions though I was firmly on the
Left at the time and I had no issue I
can remember with the Obama appointees I
was against Reid using such a drastic
tactic to me if you change the rules
when you're in power it's incredibly
obvious and probably quite deserved when
those same rules will be used against
your team when you're not in power you
can rightly blame Republicans for not
voting on the Obama appointees in 2014
just as right now you can rightly blame
Democrats for not voting on Trump
appointees in 2018
this is exactly
why people rightfully hate the political
machine in Washington it either does
nothing or it changes the rules to suit
itself while usually leaving the people
it's supposed to serve far behind the
Republicans now led by Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell could use what is known
as the nuclear option right now just as
Reid and the Democrats did back in 2014
for whatever reason though McConnell
refuses to do so some are saying he has
such an old-school affinity for the
rules of the Senate that he doesn't want
to stoop to what Reid did in a certain
way this seems like a principled
position but at this point in American
politics
I wonder if clinging on to the old ways
while your ideological opponents chisel
away at those very institutions at every
opportunity
makes much sense at all let me add
another wrinkle to this story the
highest-ranking ambassadorship that we
now have open germany has been offered
to former US spokesman for the UN
Richard Grinnell Richard is the
longest-serving UN spokesman in history
working for four different u.s.
ambassadors he's also served several
other positions in the government as
well as worked for a few other
high-level political campaigns by every
measure he's supremely qualified and
I've seen plenty of people on both sides
of the aisle that praise him as the
exact type of person that we need more
of in politics Richard and I have become
friends over the past few years and I
can personally tell you that he's truly
a decent guy who just wants to serve his
country oh and there's one other piece
to this Richard happens to be gay you
may remember back in 2012
Richard was briefly a spokesman for the
Romney campaign until the media decided
to attack an openly gay man for daring
to work for the Republican candidate
Mitt Romney thus causing Richard to step
down from the campaign because he didn't
want to be a distraction apparently
although Romney felt it was just fine to
hire a gay man and Richard felt it was
totally okay to work for Romney the
media just wouldn't let it be gay
conservatives like Richard much like
black conservatives like Larry elder or
female conservatives like nikki Haley
challenge the orthodoxy that the
Democrats must own all of these groups
of people I mentioned Richard sexuality
not because it's in
horton or even relevant unless you play
the identity politics game as so many do
in effect the Democrats are blocking an
extremely qualified openly gay man from
serving his country aren't the Democrats
and lefties supposed to be for gays
isn't that part of their intersectional
worldview immutable characteristics
often Trump qualifications if you
subscribe to this line of thinking
shouldn't this also mean supporting gay
people whose political positions you
might disagree with because you believe
in their ability to think for themselves
or perhaps the so-called tolerance ID
really isn't Pro gay or Pro any minority
they are actually only Pro those who
believe as they do now obviously you
know that I don't think anyone should be
confirmed because of their sexuality nor
should their sexuality matter in the
least when it comes to being nominated
in the first place I just think that
this particular case is interesting on
so many levels we have the gridlock of
Washington with Democrats refusing to
vote on Trump nominees we have a
majority leader in McConnell that
refuses to use his option to confirm
nominees even though the previous Senate
leader Reid did exactly just that we
have dozens of qualified candidates
waiting to do their civic duty and we
have just as many countries waiting for
our ambassadors to move there and get to
work caught in all of this mess is a
good man Richard Grinnell who I happen
to know personally who doesn't want
extra credit for being gay but just
wants to get to work how can you make a
difference in all this call your local
senator and ask their assistant at the
office why they aren't voting on these
nominees and you can also call Mitch
McConnell at his DC office by calling
two oh two two two four two five four
one actually I'm gonna give him a call
right now
[Music]
you
[Music]